welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of the
trailer for 65. the new Adam Driver
dinosaur horror film coming in March
2023 from the team behind a quiet place
and produced by Sam Raimi now while this
plot at first seems to be a kind of
Planet of the Apes deal you know
Spaceman arriving to Earth in a
different era when different species
dominated the planet not so fast because
this film doesn't really seem 100
accurate and appealing to logical sense
with some anatomical alterations to the
dinos and the fact that dinosaurs
actually went extinct 66 million years
ago but really a number of fascinating
details in this trailer if you look at
it closely make me think something else
really weird could be going on with this
movie so I'm gonna break down what you
might have missed okay we open on Mills
played by Adam Driver the commander of a
spacecraft 35 passengers reporting in
this distress call that a ship was hit
by a quote undocumented asteroid but
based on the footage it really looks
like he's flying through a whole mess of
them and then one of those chunks
naturally just collides with a ship so I
doubt all the other smaller rocks were
documented I think he might have
actually just been in cryosleep himself
and then he woke up to find his ship in
a debris field of an asteroid but who
are these 35 passengers and why were
children included well Mills calls it a
long-range exploratory Mission but I
think this is a refugee scenario these
passengers might be fleeing their home
world that has been destroyed in its own
Extinction event making this vessel a
life raft full of hopeful colonizers
thus a long-range exploratory Mission
they just went out of drift in space
trying to find another place to call
home and yeah that would make this group
of people an extraterrestrial race of
humanoids who were living 65 million
years ago and landed on Earth during
these Mesozoic times and who knows maybe
some of their DNA got left behind so
that Apes could evolve in the millions
of years to follow Adam Driver
effectively might be Earth's atom
because notice the language on his red
passenger manifest screen does not seem
to be English or any other Earth
language that I know of so yeah it looks
like out of drivers once again from a
long time ago from a galaxy far far away
but now in a dino horror franchise so
Mills charges up what looks to be a
pulse rifle not one that uses metal ammo
but rather an energy of some kind if
this is solar powered that would mean it
would only have so many rounds at night
time which would be a pretty terrifying
Prospect so of the 35 passengers he's
only found one Survivor so far this girl
KOA played by Ariana Greenblatt they at
first used breathing masks because Mills
isn't familiar with the atmospheric
conditions so yeah think about it if you
were from Earth and this is a clearly
Earth-like terrain wouldn't he recognize
it so this tells us that Mills really
does come from a planet that doesn't
really look like Earth or at least
doesn't have swamp terrain like this and
in this swamp a large thin slithers
behind him which could be a rhizodont
which was a large prehistoric freshwater
fish Mills grounds up some red powder to
Mark the trees with arrows presumably to
chart a path back to his ship or the
Escape pod wherever they've set up camp
but then there is this one insane shot
at one minute 13 seconds which seems
like a normal landscape but look at the
bottom left of frame folks those are
power columns so yes this could just be
a mistake but it's in the trailer for
the movie whatever this is this is an
industrialized planet in this shot at
least and Earth definitely would not
have had these 65 million years ago or
66 million years ago or really any time
before the mid 20th Century A.D so
really what I think we could be looking
at here is Mill's home world like a
dream of it or a flashback to it or a
prologue showing it what that planet
looks like before mills and his crew
were forced to leave it because if there
are humans that look like this
presumably they evolved on a planet that
has similar atmosphere and terrain is
Earth Mills drinks from a canteen that
purifies river water it's pretty handy
then he finds the muddy footprint of
some large theropod theropods are the
three-toe dinosaurs perhaps the
Tyrannosaurus that hunts them in the
other shots Mills says there's something
alien out there again and I know you
probably get it at this point but if you
were from Earth originally unless you
were from a society that never had
Jurassic Park movies or any natural
history museums or any cultural
awareness of dinosaurs or just didn't
believe in fossils you wouldn't call
this Predator an alien he'd be like holy
[ __ ] that's a T-Rex footprint now one of
the best things you can do for your body
is to drink tons of water but nothing's
less satisfying than just drinking a
glass of lame old plain water it's like
the definition of boring but if you use
air up you could make every sip of water
taste like really good
foreign
that's good water I mean it is just
regular water but it tastes like mango
passion fruit because this ain't no
regular water bottle this is air up air
up is an easy way to make staying
hydrated less boring it adds flavor to
your water with scent alone so you can
get all the water you need and all the
flavor you want no added powders or
sugars or anything it's really easy you
just take one of these flavor pods you
pop it on and if you're ready to taste
the magic of scent flavor pull the pot
up to activate the flavor and that's it
see the magic happens when air bubbles
carry the flavor from the Pod through
the straw and enable your brain to
experience the scent as taste it's that
easy it's so insane how this works and a
sidebar mango passion fruit is my go-to
flavor because it tastes tropical which
makes me feel tropical which makes me
think I'm on vacation and trust me if
you were me you'd agree with me and if
you wanted a break from the Flavor and
just want plain water all you got to do
is push the Pod back down see
there you go regular water though it's
the same liquid an air up makes a great
gift right now there are a ton of
discounted holiday bundles on Arab's
website that make perfect stocking
stuffers for everybody on your list
because honestly everybody needs water
if you're looking for some flavor
variety the naughty list bundle has
green air up bottle it comes with orange
vanilla raspberry lemon and mango
passion fruit flavor pod packs there are
other holiday bundles available as well
including Barry all the way dashing Duo
and B cherry and bright if you go now
you can take advantage of air UPS
holiday special to get a bundle for
yourself or for whoever you buy gifts
for 20 to 25 off each holiday bundle has
everything you need to start your air up
Journey but they'll only be available
until December 26th so hurry up and
click the link in the description make
sure you have yours in time for the
holidays Mills that go a camp out in a
cave during a rainstorm leading to this
awesome
the motion sensor lights illuminate
first yellow then red we get a great
fake out where they just appear deeper
and deeper in the cave expecting the
threat to come from the darkness but
nope it's a huge Tyrannosaurus or
perhaps an indominus Rex kind of hard to
tell the features aren't exact here but
I love how they reveal it with a flash
of lightning which is moved directly out
of the Playbook of Steven Spielberg from
Jurassic Park but again just to set some
expectations here we are getting a new
kind of dinosaur movie that's not really
gonna feel like the amblin Universal
Studios approach or really anything
we've seen from Disney and I'm really
excited about that this thing shoves his
entire freaking head into the cave as
Mills fully unloads on him then Mills
tells KOA that she's gonna have to stay
quiet and move but notice how he uses
hand signals seems like she does not
speak his language actually this could
have been a life raft of humanoids from
different regions and cultures of that
original Planet because in sci-fi
fiction does it always seem like beans
from the same Planet all speak the same
common language and all dressed the same
have the same kind of cultural identity
rather than every planet have a wide
diversity of cultures like Earth does
then we see this smaller theropod that
looks kind of like a velociraptor but
since it's smaller than a velociraptor
would be looks like just a few feet tall
I think this could be a dromaeosaurus it
peers into this hollow log where KOA is
hiding then Mills throws a few orbs
which I think are grenades they open up
to release this white energy seriously
what exactly are these I'm already
loving the unique technology that Mills
uses in this movie that the production
design seems surprisingly grounded and
lived in actually if you go through
these frame by frame it looks like there
are small jets that repel the pieces
from each other but then there's this
other glowing pocket of energy that
attracts them to each other two opposing
forces that might cause this powerful
impact glass from atop a waterfall the
dromosaurus leaps up at us well down
below the Tyrannosaurus pursues two
other smaller dinos that move through
the trees by the stream then this shot
of Mills and KOA holding each other
while debris rains from the sky is this
more part of the asteroid who knows
maybe this will be an apocalyptic
scenario and we'll just see these
characters right before that big
asteroid hits Earth and kills everything
actually maybe the asteroid field that
caused their ship to crash in the first
place was part of that same event that
sent the asteroid to Earth to Kill the
Dinosaurs oh my God maybe all those
asteroids were part of the debris of
their origin Planet exploding okay my
mind is going places connecting things
that are probably not related okay then
we see the transform attacking Mill's
Escape pod and then this final shot
I love it except do we need to put that
over dramatic cut to Black in the middle
of the shot just let the shot play out
as is please I love how at first we just
see the Mist around Mill's shoulder
blowing as the dinosaur exhales just
over his shoulder such a good horror
shot here in the as the dinosaur comes
in we brighten the darkness there you
can actually see this fella has a Crest
on his head I'm pretty sure this is the
same magnify variety with fossils that
were found in the Dakotas in Montana the
hell Creek formation referred to as anzu
named after a bird-like entity in
ancient Mesopotamian religion it's a
relatively recent species discovered in
2014. folks this trailer caught me
completely by surprise and I have really
high hopes for this movie because Adam
Driver these days doesn't really say yes
to a project unless there's something
really intriguing about it so that plus
the a quiet place guys directing it plus
Sam Raimi plus Danny help been doing the
music I mean I was ready to see it just
because dinosaurs were in it let me know
what you think about this trailer and
why they're still sticking with a title
of 65 for the movie do you follow me on
Instagram and Twitter at a boss follow
me rockstars And subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
thank you